محطات كثيره للازمات في لبنان اقتصاديه
تاره بهبوط الليره وسياسيه طاره اخرى
بالفراغ الرئاسي وفشل السياسيين في تجاوز
خلافاتهم في اختيار رئيس للجمهوريه لكن
هناك محطه جديده هي غريبه اكثر منها جديده
عقارب الساعه بعد اسبوعين من اعلان رئيس
حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقات اعتماد
التوقيت الصيفي اعتبارا من منتصف الليل
الخامس والعشرين والسادس والعشرين من مارس
الجري تراجع ميقات عن القرار مدفوعا بطلب
من رئيس مجلس النواب نبيه بري بحيث يتم
تقديم اعتبارا من منتصف ليل العشرين وال
21 من ابريل ليصبح لبنان بتوقيتين مختلفين
واحد صيفي واخر شتوي وامام تغير الفصول
ودرجات الحراره هناك ثابت وحيده معاناه
لبنانيه
[موسيقى]
مصر
الله اكبر نحن خلينا نعمل شعبي
بدل ما يكون الساعه
يظل الساعه سته من هلا رمضان
[موسيقى]